we lived in west hollywood west
hollywood is the gayest place on earth
you know rainbow crosswalks and the
whole thing and to me i would see these
guys that were you know 65 70 years old
that all they had basically was that
they worked out they spray tanned and
got hair plugs they had their little
dogs and they partied on the weekends
and probably chased the same
sexual escapades that they were chasing
40 years ago right and it's not
adolescence yeah and it's not it's not a
full life and i actually it's like i
feel i have like almost like a visceral
feeling when i talk about it because i
know that that could have been me so
when i see these people
that either at this point are against
gay marriage but but in general there
are there don't seem to be that many
voices
publicly about that anymore so here's a
rough question so do you think
both the flamboyance now i i want to get
into this in some detail but the
flamboyance that's been historically
associated with the male headers
homosexual community community sorry
about that
and
the
and the promiscuity
do you think to what degree do you think
that both of those are a consequence of
not having a more integrated and
conservative path potentially open in
front of people
so on the feminine side let's say
you you think you have the nurturance
angle
well covered you talk to me a little bit
about having women around in in your
infant and child's life as well yeah so
david's mom is going to be living with
us for a few months at the start as well
as his sister who's taken care of young
babies already
but now i understand that they're not
the biological mother but they will be
there you know we're going to have night
nurses uh also for a few months to help
the babies get on on a normal sleep
schedule but these are all the pieces
that we're trying to put together but
can we just back up for one second
because i think before we go too deep
into just the parental part of this
there was another thing that came up
when we sort of roughly sketched out
this conversation over dinner that i
think is important which is that if if
you weren't to allow gay people to
either get married and enter
relationships that will last the test of
time or have children to really last the
generations then what are we reducing
these people to
and i think that's a huge part of this
for me um that i think had the world not
shifted to be a little bit kinder had i
not maybe been on tour with you and come
to some of these realizations or found
someone in the world that i wanted to
put their needs above my own
that i could have been left to a life
that would have been sort of purely
narcissistic or self-destructive or
anything you know i used to live well i
don't see how that in some sense i don't
see how that can be
there can be any alternatives to that if
there isn't another pathway forward yes
and and so that's the to me that's like
the unknown road that i'm going down
right now that i want i'm choosing to go
down that unknown road of oh it can be
better than that right i i don't i as i
said i don't have i have two we have two
or three couples that are uh
gay parents that are doing some version
of this but we don't have that model but
then when you know we lived in west
hollywood west hollywood is the gayest
place on earth you know rainbow
crosswalks and the whole thing and to me
i would see these guys that were you
know 65 70 years old that all they had
basically was that they worked out they
spray tanned and got hair plugs they had
their little dogs and they partied on
the weekends and probably chased the
same
sexual
escapades that they were chasing 40
years ago right and it's not adolescence
yeah and it's not it's not a full life
and i actually
it's like i feel i have like almost like
a visceral feeling when i talk about it
because i know that that could have been
me so when i see these people
that either at this point are against
gay marriage but but in general there
are there don't seem to be that many
voices
publicly about that anymore so here's a
rough question so do you think
both the flamboyance now i i want to get
into this in some detail but the
flamboyance that's been historically
associated with the male headers
homosexual community community sorry
about that
and
the
and the promiscuity
do you think to what degree do you think
that both of those are a consequence of
not having a more integrated and
conservative path potentially open in
front of people
i think it's a huge amount that probably
will never be fully explained if people
don't have an ability look what was the
gay rights movement for
in the 70s in new york city and
stonewall and all of those things it was
these people just wanted well they
wanted to be able to get married that
was part of it but it was also that they
wanted to be able to go to a bar that
wasn't underground that wasn't hidden
that wasn't you know this seedy thing
but that's what they had to do because
they were getting raided by the police
and this was going on obviously in other
countries and it was going on for
decades before that
but they wanted some sense of normalcy
if you don't leave people some
little seeds of normalcy then they will
do all sorts of things so the flamboyant
part there's two parts you're asking
about so the flamboyant part i'm just
not built that way i'm not sometimes i
used to you know i used to when i was
first sort of coming out or coming to
grips with myself i actually liked guys
that were kind of flamboyant because i
in my to me it was like
oh they're so who they are
like they had just let go of every sort
of
normal cliche or something like that
they're so right they are on that kind
of existential courage yeah and yet yet
they always really like generally gays
they like straight acting that's a
that's a real thing with with gays they
like straight acting so guys always
liked me because i i didn't seem gay
whatever that meant and i thought it
sort of meant that i was broken in a
weird way because it made me feel like a
sort of like double freak in an odd
sense right right because i was
struggling here for the straight
community and too straight for the queer
community
well said man uh and and so i was sort
of grappling with that so there was this
there's the flamboyant part and then and
then you're asking about the the sex
side of it it's like if you don't leave
people with some ability to say oh you
can be in a lasting relationship this is
why marriage equality was so important
now this is a sidebar but i would never
force a church or a mosque or a
synagogue to perform a wedding that it
was against its beliefs but from a
secular perspective
to whatever uh respect we remain secular
in this country if you don't give people
the same opportunity to be in a
relationship and then learn all the
things that you talked about before how
you go through that churning with your
partner and hopefully make each other
better and sometimes make each other
worse and all that stuff
what will you leave them with you will
leave them with their carnal desires and
i definitely could have gone down that
road
with a and i definitely didn't go down
that road
rebelliousness
right because
who knows what happens if you're not
allowed so to speak to be who you are
then it strikes me as highly probable
that
an excessive amount of
rebelliousness is going to start to look
attractive right and maybe to be
indistinguishable from courage i would
say it's got to be the case that the
hope so to speak of the more enlightened
conservative types who were willing to
open the door to gay marriage was that
by bringing those relationships inside
the traditional fold that things would
normalize yeah
and that there would be a promotion of
something like stable mature responsible
long-term monogamy well i think maybe
i'm trying to prove that yeah i'm not
i'm not trying to prove it like i'm
setting it out to prove it but i suppose
de facto because of my life i'm trying
to prove that i mean in a weird way
although i'm probably the unlikeliest of
conservatives in that sense it's like
what life am i trying to live i'm trying
to live a life that is somewhat
conservative in nature in that sense
meaning that i believe that family is
important and probably the most
important thing after the individual
that's that's how societies are built i
fundamentally believe that so it's weird
it's like my
my world view because otherwise what are
you saying to people so okay okay you're
gay so you can either just
endlessly have sex or endlessly
disregard every norm known to man
and just have nothing other than wake up
and just live life how you want what
other way is there to integrate into
society to really integrate into society
i mean to me this this is it if you'd
like to see more honest and insightful
conversations with jordan peterson
himself check out our jordan peterson
playlist which includes every interview
i've ever done with him and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
both are right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell